[Music]
to put it plainly I suck at being
married I'm on my third one it's on thin
ice now I have trouble working together
on projects she wants to help she asks
me questions I shrink into myself I shut
down why haven't you sat down and said
hey I want to bring you into my life but
I can't Steve are you seeing somebody
[Music]
else hey what's up this is on with the
Dr John deloney show taking your calls
on mental and emotional health and your
marriage and
relationships that crummy interaction
you have with your boss to start the new
year or you and your spouse he'll just
want your marriage to be different you
don't know where to start you get that
kid coming in and they might as well be
from another planet because you don't
even know what in the world's going on
whatever you have going on in your life
when it comes to your relationships your
emotional mental health actually I'll
just comment on anything if you want to
but those are the things I kind of know
uh about that and how much the Astros
are superior to all the baseball teams
and uh I'm sorry who won the World
Series here we go here we go was I don't
think it was the Astros was it listen
listen it's good to just spread the love
every once in a while the Yan listen of
the Rangers the Y the Yankees and
Alabama football found out the Patriots
what happens when you win every year
everybody just hates you so every couple
years the Astros they take one for the
team they say pretty much I think
everybody hates the Astros too yeah
right that's so if you are struggling
with a coworker because your cooworker
is judgmental and I mean relatively
insane and can't see up or down and has
no clear understanding about how
rational thinking works I think if
people out there get it exactly so if I
if I'm the guy to help I'm the guy to
help because God helped me with what I
have to deal with here on the show but
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at 1 1844 693 3291 it's 1844 693
3291 or go to john.com
[Music]
askas K and please it makes such a huge
difference subscribe to the show on
YouTube please um we're really doing a
subscription drive this year the numbers
of the show have just grown we have so
we have countless more people with us on
a regular basis it's really exciting um
and we're going to really push for Subs
subcribes and likes and so please please
please help us out but more importantly
than us man we're fine help out your
neighbor who just doesn't know and
they're going to finally get the courage
to go stick into the YouTube heading
they're going to Google into the top of
YouTube I know that I just that make
sense but they're going to write in the
the search in YouTube like my marriage
is falling apart how do I help and if
you keep hitting the Subscribe button it
really gives them an opportunity to have
this show dumped into their algorithm
and they can get the life change that
they need so thank thank you so so much
for all of your help all right let's go
out to Dallas
Texas oh great probably another Rangers
Fan and talk to Steve hey Steve what's
up hey I was going to say uh with the
Astros and
the uh Patriots you know once a cheater
always a cheater oh I knew it I knew
it we got our first our first title so
you know I'll give you this one it feels
good the first time doesn't it it's just
so exciting tell every it was amazing it
was amazing and I lived in Houston for a
couple years so I I feel your love all
right I'm there AST Astros rule all
right what's up Steve by the way Steve
you're a very smart human and I think
you're the
best thank you thank you um KY does
drugs all right so what's up I I just I
to put it plainly I suck at being
married I'm on my third one um it's on
thin ice now we've been together nine
years and married almost five um couple
of things I have trouble working
together on projects that she thinks we
should like cleaning out the garage or
working on the barn taking care of the
lawn stuff like that um she wants to
help she asks me questions or make
suggestions or whatever and I I shrink
into myself I shut down I get short with
my answers and comments to her I
normally feel like I do best just
figuring it out myself and doing doing
it that way um secondly I hidden
purchases from her over the years um
I've had my family buy gifts for friends
with my own spending money but I haven't
told her about it tried to hide things
I've done from her uh for instance I
went I was going to go hunting and I
decided to go fishing instead and I
didn't tell her um until she found out
afterwards um I've also talked with my
brother about things that she does that
bothers me but I've exaggerated them and
I've not told the whole truth
um or told the entire story
accurately uh these Tendencies have
definitely increased over the past year
to I feel controlled by her discipline
with money or her questioning me about
things so I've resorted to not sharing
some things in an effort to avoid her
questioning me on things um that's part
of the problem I feel like I have to ask
permission for some things that I really
feel I really normally shouldn't have to
ask for um obviously nothing justifies
what I've done but I feel controlled I
feel like these things eek out of me as
a cry for autonomy I definitely don't
want to be anonymous I just want some
autonomy I feel like I'm lacking
autonomy um she's found out about all of
these things she's so now she has of
course severe trust issues um she's
plainly stated that I'll never gain her
trust again which I understand um
definitely I can say that asking
forgiveness is not better than and
asking for permission so there's no
justification for my actions but I do
feel like they're a reactive behavior
and I just don't know how
to um I guess stand up for myself on
some things that I feel like I should be
able to do or want to do without getting
pushed back and then it gets all jumbled
up and I just it turns into a
mess so it sounds
like I mean you're you're taking full
ownership so I'm going to keep you at
your I'm going to hold you to your word
you're taking your ownership it sounds
like you've done some stupid stuff that
is is um I wouldn't advise anyone to do
it also sounds like you're married to a
brutal
person she's not brutal for sure she's
she's
just um let's do this let's I want I
want to Circle back you said you're not
good at being married are these the same
patterns that showed up in marriage one
and two why did those marriages Fall
Apart
um first one I felt I was too
controlling in the relationship and um
it was not really sure why it fell apart
I know that I I had Parts I was I was
just too controlling over stupid little
things like hanging your towel and a
rack and stuff like that um and she left
you she did okay yep all right the
second one was only 6 months it's a long
story but it just it shouldn't have
happened in the first place
um I don't know how to really describe
that but it wasn't a match from the
beginning okay the hard the hard part
the hard part about what you just
described with your current Wedding
Marriage not wedding but your current
marriage is it's really tough to chicken
or
egot has she found herself increasingly
more controlling and paying attention to
everything and really trying to hem you
in because you're just a dude who just
is just dishonest and you just kind of
do your own life and you don't want
anyone you you kind of want a a wife but
you don't you want the idea of a wife
but you don't want to do the work that
it takes to have a real wife and she is
clinging so tightly to just shreds of of
of intimacy and relationship that you're
starting to get choked by it or man
you've really worked hard yeah you've
been a knucklehead but for crying out
loud I'm going hunting and so now I'm
going fishing it's not I don't know that
there needs to be a big public
announcement but then she here comes the
Grinch and she is yelling I can't
believe you lied to me and you're like
dude it doesn't it's it's it's fish not
Birds right or fish not deer what's the
big deal so what do you think is what do
you think it is I go back and forth on
it and
um it's I think obviously a little bit
of both
um I felt probably a little constricted
and then just or just wanted to do my
own thing and then she found out about
that and then it's gotten probably
Tighter and then I've reacted more uh
you know in response to that over the
years lately it she she's
definitely she's got her radar on which
I know is what you've said you know the
radar is a is her radar is working
perfectly um so she's hyper sensitive or
you know on the lookout for things that
makes me want to just do more things
that and you know so yeah I feel so part
of it is I feel he's going to have an
issue with something so I just like the
fishing instead of hunting and
um it was it just so I just went and did
it and then she found out later so I
want to share those things with her but
I feel like everything a lot of things
are kind of a bigger production all
right so why why have you never said
that exact
sentence cuz I hunt I hunt a lot and I'm
trying to think if I told my wife hey
we're heading out to go hunting tomorrow
morning and I leave way before she I
leave like at 4 in the morning so I head
out and I get to where we're going and
one of my buddies shows up and he's like
dude let's go fishing and I'm like no
and he talks me into
it right I can't imagine that I would
feel this big be feel compelled I might
text my wife when I knew she was awake
just in case something happened that she
would know I'm on a lake somewhere but
like we have that trust established that
she'd be like I don't I mean you're not
here I don't care what you're do you see
what I'm saying right so why haven't you
said I'm trying to even make that a big
deal in my house and it's just not but
why haven't you sat down and said hey I
want to bring you into my life but I
can't or we have wasn't uh I don't feel
there was a big resolution on it but we
I that was our latest conversation was I
want to share these things with her but
I don't feel that I can sometimes but
can you not because she is an
overbearing
nag it's her way for sure is that is
that true or is it because you don't
want to you don't want to do marriage
with somebody you just want your own
life you don't want anyone tell you how
to do the yard you don't want to tell
you when to do the yard you don't anyone
to tell you about your clothes your life
your house anything I want the towel
hung up where I want it hung up I want
everything to be the way it is and what
you're looking for actually is you want
a maid you want you want an
employee no not that for sure okay then
what is it man because here's the deal
at the end of the day y'all are choosing
this misery that you
have right both of y'all are making
choices for everything in your life to
suck and I I can't wrap my head around
why you're choosing
this we
are ordinarily we have this amazing
connected relationship we even share the
same pillow we're and like that's around
us I'm just kidding I'm kid I figured
you'd say that we travel with one pillow
and we share it and we're we are like
siese twins when we sleep it's just okay
so why do you lie about your wife to
your
brother I felt more and more stifled
about I don't give a crap about that I
don't care how you felt why did you lie
about your wife to your brother I know
it's that's that's the part that I've
done just answer the question though yo
are you trying to are you trying to like
distance yourself from your wife are you
trying to be cool in front of your
brother like why did you
lie about your wife to your
brother um what did that get
you
nothing it got her angry at me why did
you hide purchases why did you like in
my world I call that Financial
infidelity why' you cheat on your on
your wife when it comes to
money even routing even laundering money
through family members to buy things for
other people yeah I don't have an excuse
for
it so your wife's not here I think that
you're covering up for her in a pretty
noble way but she sounds like she's
tough on
you so but she but I can't talk to her
she's she's not here right what I'm
gonna tell different go ahead sorry we
just have we have some different views
on money um what is your view on money
you should be able to spend it whenever
you want whatever you want because it's
yours no no no no no not at all our
money's combined we get a little bit of
spending money each month for each other
um
that's supposed to be fun play
unaccountable money
um and most time it is I think she's I
think she wonders what I spend it on
um so Steve are you seeing somebody else
no not a chance not a
chance the more I'm the more you're
talking the more I'm thinking the more
there something something feels off I
feel like I'm missing a piece of a
puzzle
here no there is absolutely zero no not
even in the same universe okay promise
you on that okay I just like to go I
feel like if I went and bought um lunch
for myself out she's wondering what I
did for lunch and I didn't save the
receipt for our taxes and so it's still
accountable I feel like I just want to
go get some lunch is it because she
loves
you is that her way of trying to connect
with you hey man why you have for lunch
today yeah it is for sure and then for
some reason I feel like she's keeping
tabs on me I have a thing about that is
she I don't think so
okay then here's I really don't think so
then here's the deal you have to decide
because the things you've told me can be
one of two things and I'm just being
honest and it's hard in this short of a
conversation especially without her if
you ever want to call back with her on
the phone that would be fun man but
here's the deal
either she is borderline
pathological she's like the Deep State
she wants to know what you a eat where
you are at all times she wants to know
what you spend and why you spent it and
who you spent it with and you can't have
a marriage like that unless you are
somebody cheated on somebody and you are
creating a you are reestablishing trust
and then for a season you have to live
like that sure right either that's the
case or there is a woman who is
desperately she is so desperately trying
to connect with you she asks you about
lawn care for God's
sakes and you're just like leave me
alone
lady what' you have for lunch today my
God will you quit hassling
me well hey I'll do the taxes did you
get the receipt oh my and bro
why that's what I was hoping to get
helped with I don't know why I have this
uh that's why you're the one I she's not
a nag she cares about me we care deeply
about each other but I I just I resist
some things and I don't know why
why do you hate
Steve I don't know you can't stand
Steve and if Steve gets brought out of a
shadow at any at any level from what
Steve had for
lunch for who Steve dated in high school
to what Steve's thinking Steve feels
buck naked in Time Square totally
exposed and terrified and he lashes out
or he goes undercover to keep Steve from
being seen cuz Steve doesn't want anyone
to see Steve because Steve doesn't like
Steve true or
false they're
um do you struggle with
pornography no no what's your
advice
my vice is uh well I like to buy
things how much have you bought that she
doesn't know
about that she doesn't know about
nothing she knows about
everything
okay here's the deal I love you enough
to tell you this brother this ends in
divorce unless you decide that you're
worth being in a relationship with
period and that means you have to let
some people connect with
you and if something
like um my
goodness when I used to do a lot of
crisis response stuff I was showing up
to to people's homes and there was dead
bodies there was body parts there were
brains all over the place
and my wife tried to connect with me and
I finally said hey you don't want to
know what I'm seeing at
night so I don't and I don't feel
comfortable talking about it but I will
tell you last night was a really rough
one and when I say that it would really
mean a lot to me if you just give me a
hug or one night after I had to show up
and there was some kids that had passed
away it was a real gnarly situation I
woke up I went in my kids room and
Hank's room he was really young and I
just held him and he was dead asleep and
then I come out of his room and it was
like in the middle of the night I said
to I had to hold my
son and the next morning my wife was
like man were you in the what were you
doing and I was like hey you know I
don't want to talk about so there's that
if you feel that strongly about the yard
hey this is my Sacred Space and I know
it's so weird but I feel awkward talking
about the
yard be honest and be brave enough be a
man enough to say here's what I
need but it's just cruel to beat up
somebody for for wanting to connect with
the man that she said she
loves especially if the only reason he
doesn't want to connect is because he
doesn't love
himself
right do you believe you're worth being
loved
man
sometimes I think you
are here's here's I mean here's my path
forward for you man and I know this is
brief you and I could probably talk for
another couple hours and I'd love just
to go have a drink with you one day
um I get a sense from you that it is
exhausting to be
you that's how much grief you carry
about you how much
disdain and you have to hear me say my
friend please I know we're on the phone
and you can't see me please listen to
this your wife is trying to love you and
you're worth that love
period any story countered to that is
not true
it's a
lie and so the goal here is to stop
running from that woman loves me and to
start leaning into okay I'm going to
practice being uncomfortable in her
presence I'm going to tell her that I
love you so much and every time you try
to connect with me my body screams
you're not worth
her and it has to stop now and that's
nothing she's gonna have to fix you're
gonna have to be the guy that says I am
going to allow myself to be
seen and that's going to start with you
keeping a Daily Journal
practice it's going to be you deciding
on a weekly basis to sit with your wife
and say how can I love you this
week that's going to be you deciding to
go see a counselor because you have to
go seek some professional help for this
period dude period stay on the line I'll
get you three free months with my
friends a better help I'm I'll at least
get you going you can start seeing
somebody with the next 24 48
hours but it sounds to me like your wife
is desperate and she's getting to the
end of her rope she's saying dude I've
been trying to connect with you for so
long and I'm tired of going to war and
get my hand bit off every time I reach
out to hold
yours you have to decide to enter into a
season of discomfort where you learn to
love yourself where you learn what it
feels like to be loved from someone else
when you learn to drop your shoulders
and say I don't care how the Yard Works
cuz that's my
wife I don't care where my towels are
today that's my
wife and then in those moments that you
do need something you don't say you need
to do this you say hey
um when I go to lunch I don't think it
through I just order like a sandwich or
whatever I don't pay attention and when
I get home for some reason it feels like
I'm being attacked I feel attacked I'm
working on
that but I promise if I don't know what
I had for lunch and I didn't keep the
receipt I'm I'm not I mean I'm not
trying to hide anything from you I love
you I just don't think through lunch
that much but I can't wait for
[Music]
dinner I feel like this one's going to
going
to be a long time working through Steve
you call me anytime and we'll get you
back on the show
man those are a few steps you can get
going hang on the line we'll hook you up
with better help and I'll hook you up
with building a non- anxious life my
latest look give you a place to start
we'll be right
back Today's Show is made possible by
some of the greatest powders and potions
on the planet organifi listen I bought
organifi with my own money after several
of my brilliant muscled up friends kept
ranting and raving about them how great
they were how much they changed their
life and now I take them every single
day my wife and kids are in on it and
they are an essential part of my
Wellness routine here's the deal
organifi makes everything easy it's a
powder that you mix with water and by
the way they also have capsule
supplements like magnesium that I also
take but then you mix it with water you
drink it and then you're off to the
races or you're off to a really deep
sleep I take organifi every day but for
my go-tos I take the green juice and the
red juice every day the green juice to
level me out and give me the critical
micros that I need and the red juice to
get me ready to rock and roll without
mainlining caffeine which I've done for
far too long my family and I have also
been taking immunity for daily immune
support while everyone we know has been
getting sick and not feeling well these
products are some of the cleanest in the
world and they are delicious my whole
family loves them and they are some of
my goto supplements organifi is hooking
up our show listening gang with 20% off
all organifi products even the kids line
go to organifi.com dealone or use promo
code delone at checkout that's o r g n
ii.com dealone or use promo code deloney
at
checkout all right let's go out to
Danville Illinois and talk to Jane
what's up Jane hey what's up partying
what are you
doing uh sitting here chatting with you
I have a question okay what's up uh okay
so one morning I was listening to your
podcast and you said we marry our
unfinished
business and I have never heard anyone
say that before and I was wondering if
you could explain what that means oh
yeah I love to it's a great question um
so I I don't even remember when I said
that I've probably said that multiple
times on this show
um some would go as far as to say it is
a uh nervous system wiring that it's
it's that deeply embedded in you um but
I know it's it's common venacular among
therapists particularly relationship
therapist and here's the
idea let's say um you're
a little girl let's do this let's make
you the example can we make you the
example Jane sure okay uh tell me about
how you grew up tell me about your
dad uh okay I didn't meet my dad until I
was in my 30s
okay what happened where'd he
go uh I don't know um I met him uh well
I flew out to Colorado's medium and uh
then he came back to Illinois to visit
for a little bit no no why did he leave
you in the first Place why did a husband
like a why did a dad abandon the most
precious thing on planet Earth which is
a little
girl what I was told from my mom um was
that when she told him that she was
pregnant he left okay um so I never knew
him my whole life um my aunt found a
newspaper clipping um and she sent it to
me when I was in my 30s and said I think
these are your grandparents
and so I looked them up they live in the
same Hometown that I grew up in I don't
live in that Hometown anymore um and so
found him got in touch with him things
were great uh flew out to Colorado met
him um and then you know I came back
home obviously and then he came for a
visit to
Illinois and we like exchanged letters
and he would send gifts for me and my
husband and my kids and things like that
and that went on for a little
while and then he started I don't know
it was really weird like he would he
wanted to come and visit me but he would
call me and ask me questions about my
mom and then he would call my mom and
ask her questions about
me and she told him you know if you're
just coming to get with me then stay
where you're at but if you're coming to
see Jane then I'll you know absolutely
come and visit her and he was coming to
visit me but he would call me and ask me
if he would be okay to stay with my mom
so it was like really weird um so when
she told him that he never contacted me
ever again and so I haven't heard from
him since and I'm fine with that
um okay I've lived 30 years without him
I not you know I don't think about it
anymore um I figure you know found out
what I needed to know about my past on
his side of the family okay I did meet
my grandparents they were wonderful
people um and I'm just really grateful
that I grew up with my mom and her
parents and not the other way around so
awesome so tell me about tell me about
your mom to much of it uh my mom she's
well she just passed away um a little
over a year ago uh in April it'll be two
years and um
she oh gosh she had three kids by three
different people um she was married but
the people that she was married to was
not the fathers of any of us um so did
you have did you have a household of of
stepdads uh not a whole lot um maybe
like two or three um one of them wasn't
for very long
um mainly we grew up my mom lived with
her parents so like my entire life until
I moved out for college I lived with my
grandparents and my mom
okay so I I'm gonna take a wild
just um these kind of statements like
you mirry your unfinished business those
aren't um always etched in concrete okay
mhm but it would not be uncommon for for
someone who had experienced the life you
experienced and I want to be real clear
to The Listener Jane can you and I just
talk like super no one's listening to us
except for a couple million people is
that cool real quick just a private to
the side yeah you gave me the very
sanitized version of your childhood Fair
yes very sanitized yeah very very
sanitized okay so it would not be
uncommon for someone who grew up in the
home that you grew up
in to very much be a
pursuer and a people pleaser someone who
made sure everybody else was okay oh
yeah that's me 100% okay so when I say
you marry your unfinished
business the sentiment is your nervous
system not your not this isn't a
character issue or what your
body is asking what was so bad about me
that that guy
left all those years
ago right what was so bad about me that
stepdad a came in for just a little bit
and hung out with me and then took off
was I not good enough for him
either and then what happens is your
body asks that question over and over
and over and over and over again what
about me what is so bad about me and you
start to solve that
problem I will be the nobody will
have any uh sweat on their glasses I'm
going to wipe it all off everyone's
going to have a meal in front of them
the laundry is going to be done I am
going to be and what without thinking it
without meaning to you find yourself in
another romantic relationship where
you're
chasing and you end up trying to prove
yourself to somebody else and to
somebody else and to somebody else no no
no I'm worth it I'm worth it I promise
I'm worth it I promise prom I'm worth
it okay and so that doesn't mean that's
who you end up with over time that
doesn't mean that that plays its way out
in every
situation but if you Jane have found
yourself exhausted in marriage over the
last 15 20 30
years or you've got kids now that you
love you love your husband but not one
person has ever asked Jane what do you
want to do
then there might be worth asking have
you spent your adult life trying to make
sure that nobody ever leaves you again
even if that cost you the things that
you are really interested in the big
curious questions about how the universe
worked that you wanted to pursue but you
were too busy making sure everybody else
could pursue
them and that may not be you I don't
want to cast that on you but I'm just
using you as an example of that would be
marrying your unfinished business and
sometimes you marry somebody who's
amazing and he'll never
leave often people who went through what
you went through as a kid are on
marriage number
four because they marry people who leave
and they try so desperately to solve
that and they can't because it was never
their problem to begin with your dad
left because something was wrong with
that dude not
you
yeah how's that ringing
true
uh the the husband part I'm he's my
first husband um we've been married for
28 years and oh 29 years we just had an
anniversary in November congratulations
and um thank you and um but the people
pleaser definitely that is 100% me I'm
I'm very much a people pleaser I will
I'll apologize for things that just to
keep the peace there you go like yeah
um but yeah
like I know my sister and I have
different views on the way we see my mom
as we grew up um so I don't know I'm
just always like trying to see the
positive of things and here's the deal
you're probably both right by the way y
are probably both right yeah we are
because I agree with what she says um
but I I guess I just choose to see the
positive and not dwell on the negative
and what I would tell you is when I say
something like uh your body
knows you go looking every day for the
most positive attributes your mom has
because why not right why not what is
just at this stage in the game what is
revisiting all this ugly gonna do right
right let's find the positive and let's
let's sit on
that there's some real value in that but
you you have to honor both sides of the
Ledger because your body is still trying
to protect you all the
time so if your mom was
unstable yet she showed up and
provided if your mom paraded a bunch of
unsafe men through your house through a
household of little
girls but man we never missed a freaking
meal both things are
true and there's some safety in that
where you exhale and drop your shoulders
and you're like ah
I'm never going to miss a meal with her
the heat is never going to get turned
off because she works her butt off
she'll do whatever it takes and there's
a high alert in your nervous system
waiting for who's coming in the door
next or in your case who's going to
leave
next I do get very um I know my kids
have pointed out to me a lot that I get
very uh judgmental okay when or not
judgmental but defensive when somebody
body judges me I get very very defensive
because that's all you
got because if you're found to be less
than boom now they have reason to go
which is your body's worst possible
fear it sounds like you did not marry
your unfinished business so kudos to you
did you marry an amazing guy that's good
huh did you marry an amazing man yes
awesome I he's not perfect but I'm not
perfect so I mean I am so I mean y'all
two of course none of us are right none
of us are no of course but no he's he's
a great husband great father awesome the
idea so hey great great question the
idea of marrying your unfinished
business is those core issues that came
up when we were
kids why did you
leave how did I make you so angry that
you had to hit me that
much why was my why was Perfection why
were my grades and how nice my bed was
made why was that more important than
you hugging
me those things get wired into us and we
go looking to solve that problem down
the
road and I'll keep saying this to blue
in the face that problem is never the
kid it's always the adult in the
room and then we
often crash into a spouse and our body
goes ah this one feels familiar I'll
solve this one this guy's really
aggressive and I see how angry he is but
I'm gonna be so loving he won't hit
me I'm gonna fix this Cosmic Loop and
then
bam I'm gonna this guy he's I could tell
man I can feel it he leaves He Cheats
he's not g to cheat on me I'm gonna be
the most perfect wife who ever existed
my dad cheated on my mom my granddad
cheated on my grandmother it stops with
me and that dude goes in cheats too
because your body's solving for
homeostasis and safety all the time and
those two things
Collide great great question Jane thank
you so so much I want to tell you man
I'm proud of
you cuz for a sanitizers you told that
you grew up in a really tough tough
environment and it sounds like of course
you're not perfect but it sounds like
you stood in front of the fire and
you've changed things for your family
you've got a steady marriage over 30
years you got grown kids kids proud of
you you've given your kids a chance to
continue to change that Legacy into
something that's going to be beautiful
you planted seeds to trees you're never
going to get to eat the fruit of I'm
proud of you Jane we'll be right
back New Year's is my favorite time of
the year and this year I'm committed to
finally establishing an ongoing
journaling routine developing a
consistent and guided daily prayer
practice as well as getting back to
meditating and doing my coherence
breathing exercises on a daily basis
one place where I can do all of this in
the same location is with my favorite
app in the world hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app on planet Earth it
has over 10,000 audio guided prayers
meditations and music I use the guided
prayers in scripture readings for my
personal development I listen to the
lowii Beats while I Journal I'm a sucker
for good Loi and occasionally when
things get sideways I return to the app
in the afternoon for peace throughout
the day whether you're a person of
Christian faith who is looking to R knew
your way of living or you're curious
about all this Faith talk and you just
want to explore hallow is for you for
listeners of the Dr John deloney show
you get three free months of hallow all
10,000 plus prayers meditations music
the lecture series and more all of it by
going to hall.com
dealone that's three free months of the
app at hall.com
deloney all right let's go down the
street to my hometown Nashville and talk
to to Lexi what's up
Lexi hi how's it going rocking and
rolling what are you up to good nothing
much just trying to call my nerves about
this call but oh you're all good you're
all good what's up um okay so I have a
kind of description that I'm just going
to read because this topic is even hard
for me to kind of explain um so I hope
that's okay but I am a very anxious and
I guess you could say paranoid person I
was diagnosed with postpartum depression
around months ago but my doctor felt
like the main cause of that was my
sleeping habit as long as I can remember
I've been scared of very irrational
things um it's pretty embarrassing to
admit honestly since um I'm an adult now
but I remember feeling this way as a
child um and I feel like it got a lot
worse in high school but as an adult I
still struggle with this it affects my
everyday life um I can pinpoint certain
characters that I've seen in TV shows or
on the news that trigger me more than
others but um mostly when I'm alone or
when it's dark my mind is pretty much
convinced that the same episodes I've
seen on these TV shows are going to
happen to me even though I know it's not
real so I don't sleep well because I'm
super anxious I have one eye open and I
just last night was up for hours with
just super anxious and paranoid
thoughts yeah I know that's a lot well I
was going to say welcome to my club I
happy to have you as another Charter
Member you just described me about 12
years ago so well that makes me feel
good it is awesome to have you so good
you I really hope you can help because
I've seen um three or four therapists
over the years and nobody's ever been
able to help me or even give me like
Sound Advice that helps me get to the
next step so I'm like I feel like if
anybody could help it would be you so
well I appreciate that um what what are
some things that they have told you to
what are some attempts they have made in
the past
um so I did the first therapist I saw I
was in high school um my mom had just
seen multiple episodes of me having
pretty much panic attacks because I
would get so scared of things that were
clearly not real um so I went to a
therapist and his ideas were to at the
time I was like scared of taking a
shower when I was alone because I had
seen a show where a serial killer killed
girls in the shower so I would not
shower if nobody was home so he just
encouraged me to do that when no one was
there and proved to myself that nothing
was going to happen um and that didn't
really help at all um and then as an
adult I've seen therapist and they
pretty much just tell me to change my
thoughts or to pray and as much as like
I want that to help it just hasn't done
anything for me oh man hey if you were
here I would ask is it okay if I just
hook you for a minute I'm
sorry yeah it's pretty hard I'm really
over it yeah I could see so you're um
the guy you actually saw in high school
was was closer to the truth okay okay um
now had I been working with a teenager I
would not have done it that way because
it's pretty abrupt what he was doing was
the the the nerd word is exposure
therapy and so let's take a snake let's
say you have a phobia of a snake and
like you can't breathe you don't sleep
like snakes snakes snakes Snak snakes
snakes right yeah what they'll do in
especially with youngsters but even with
adults is they will start with you just
sitting in the room and I want you to
imagine a
snake and we'll do that for like and
then we'll play a we'll play a game like
just to cleanse your your mental pallet
and then all right you're G to for five
for five seconds for 15 seconds you're
going to picture a
snake and then it moves gradually
towards you're going to color a coloring
book that I have here which is like like
clearly children's cartoons of snakes
you're going to color it we're going to
going to do it together and as an adult
you feel like this is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever done it's
embarrassing but you color it and what
you're slowly doing over time and you
end up with the last session is he
brings in a giant snake or you'll go to
the zoo and you hold a snake
together because what you've done is
you've gently over time taught your body
tiny step by tiny step that that's going
to we're going to be
okay now I want to suggest to you
something totally different that's what
he was trying to do and I actually think
there would have been some help there
back when you were a kid but just going
basically what he did was all right just
go to the zoo and hold a snake you'll be
fine and your body was like pretty much
like no so yeah he skipped a bunch of
steps but I want to ask you a different
kind of question okay okay what
if what if your body's
right
um that's a good question question let
me ask you this guess I'm gonna I'm
gonna say this um and it's going to
sound crazy I don't think there's
something wrong with
Lexi okay
okay I don't think something's wrong
with
you I want to at least sit for a minute
with the idea that Lexi's body is
working
perfectly so if that was the
case and we backed out 30,000 feet and I
was sitting right next to you so we're
all good
yeah what does Lexi scar
of that's a good question I've tried to
think about this um a few times and it's
let me say it differently I asked it
wrong yeah what is Lexi's body trying to
protect her
from um I I really don't like the
feeling of being scared I think that's
like above a layer above where I guess
you're probably trying to go but I don't
like that's the feeling of being scared
is something I think I'm scared of okay
absolutely and so like for example last
night I heard a it was storming in
Nashville I'm sure you heard it was it
was mad house my daughter ended up in
our bed yeah was a whole thing yeah oh
gosh yeah it was loud and I heard
something that ended up being our
shutter fell off our house but in the
middle of the night I heard the bang and
in my head I was like okay someone just
came in our backyard they're going to
come kill us like there my kids are
going to have to watch I had these crazy
thoughts spiraling throughout my head
and I like fully believed that that was
about to happen Okay and the feeling of
like the anxiety and just like the
waiting I guess is really what triggers
me the most was like I couldn't relax
because I just was like so sure
something was coming and I don't know I
want to suggest something else yeah
that's that's a drug for
Lexi okay you get
high off the flood of adrenaline and
cortisol and here it comes it's showtime
it's game time now
mhm and when you don't have that in your
real life and maybe you grew up you I
could sit down for an hour and by the
way you're Nashville come down and visit
me in the studio that'd be fun we can
hang out but like like for you're like
yeah for sure never going to happen ever
so
um if you grew up in a wild situation in
an unsafe home your body put a GPS pin
in in these moments of I'm Free Falling
m okay and maybe you didn't maybe you
grew up in a perfectly safe home and
cool but if no I did okay so if you grew
up in chaos or not yeah in chaos okay so
think of it this way your body put a GPS
pin in at any moment this thing comes
down and it is simply all the time 247
365 your body is trying to take care of
Lexi yeah it's just trying to take care
of you and so it has put a bunch of GPS
pins in darkness and in noise and in
hovering scary pictures do you have an
do you have abuse in your
background um kind not um physically but
mental yeah
okay yeah from I had a pretty rough
relationship with my dad and there were
quite a few episodes um that happened as
a child my mom is convinced that that's
what this is all rooted in but um but
but but when when somebody says like oh
it's all rooted in this what they're
going to tell you is so now that's not
there just get over it yeah and what I
want to tell you is it's baked into your
nervous system it's part of you so your
body is is working
great the one freaking guy that was
supposed to take care of be the safe
warm place for his daughter went to war
with
her right yeah and so you pull that
image away and your brain goes searching
for the next image to plop in there and
you just happen to sit down in front of
a TV show where someone's getting hacked
up in a shower
yeah and you're like oh that's how it
will happen yeah and then eventually you
have to take a shower you have to and
you figure it out and figure it out and
figure it out and your body goes all
right we're that's not it it's G to be
this and it just keeps moving and moving
and moving and
moving I would be stunned and I never
ever ever ever do this on this show
okay I in fact I'm not going to do it on
the show I want you to go talk to a
counselor and I want you to ask if they
will give you an OCD diagnostic or an
OCD um analysis okay okay I would be
surprised if there's not some sort of
the trend line between OCD and anxiety
is very thin but when I sat down with
the doctor and walked through and he was
like oh dude clearly right here it it
gave me so much
peace okay okay yeah that's interest
because I almost included in my question
I don't have I'm not diagnosed with OCD
but I'm pretty sure that I
I want you to go don't don't do a Google
diagnostic because that is but I do want
you to go talk to somebody and say hey
would you give me an inventory and see
if this is what this
is because it just moves because my my
get my your doctor's right nothing in
your body works if you're not sleeping
yeah how old's your
baby um I have a one-year-old she just
turned one and then a six-year-old and
an eight-year-old stepson so how um we
have a busy house how how dark can we
get real
quick quick whatever whatever you you
think did you have some looping pretty
awful
thoughts yeah I did um and we also had
my daughter had really serious health
issues um last May and um she she pretty
much did die um at the hospital and they
were able to save her but that
definitely spiraled me as well um but
hold on you had some thoughts that that
you were concerned if somebody knew it
was in your mind they're going to take
your kids didn't you oh yeah yeah for
sure okay
yeah and then you take those thoughts
and you bury them in the deepest
recesses of your soul and you can't
sleep you can't breathe and then your
machine Loops up again and it goes in
again and it goes in again and then is
your husband a pretty good guy he is
yeah he actually is the one that told me
about your show so thankful well he's
he's grasping at a ghost cuz he loves
you so much he doesn't know how to reach
you cuz you're so far inside of
yourself yeah but I need you to hear me
say you're not
broken thank you do you trust
me yes I trust you I know it's weird to
think that your body's working just as
it should here's what we have to do it's
um there's like a you ever been in the
shower and it's facing in the door and
so you open the the shower door and you
turn on the shower and it shoots you
right in the face and you're in your
full clothes and you're like what
because it's just the all we need to do
here is turn the kn nozle the other
way your body's working great it has
just identified Darkness as the end of
time it is identified loud noises or
scary thoughts as it's all over now and
it is not something that you can think
or just quote unquote prey your way out
of it is a biochemical response your
body dumps cortisol in Adrenaline into
your body that's why you can't sleep has
nothing to do with you being crazy it
has to do with your body is filled with
fight or flight
chemicals yeah I always say I'm like if
I could run a marathon it would be in
the middle of the night exactly and you
just lay in bed and you're like all
right well I'm just going to lay here
I'm gonna lay here right yeah yeah and
then no matter how much you're just
laying there at 6:14 can I have a snack
can I have a snack right it just starts
up again yeah yep okay pretty much
that's how it goes you're not
crazy that feels good to hear okay
you're not crazy yeah so I want to give
you you got a lot of work ahead of you
I'm not going to lie to you okay I do
think there's
um I'm gonna send you both of my books
because I wrote them for
you okay a lot of people get a lot of
benefit from them but I wrote them for
you because you and I have very similar
situations okay that's helpful yeah
thank you I want you to know this though
you're going to have to be willing to
let this go as an
identity okay not the you're going to
have to just force yourself in a scary
moment you are going to have to do that
but that's down the road what I'm saying
is right now you have identified
yourself as I'm an anxious parent an
anxious person and I'm scared of being
scared yeah the problem is you wear that
as a as a
badge as a label that you've put on your
lapel yeah that's true and I want that
crap
gone you're a awesome badass mom and
wife who grew up in hell and has done a
pretty amazing job with three little
ones of her own that's who you
are you're not a scaredy whatever your
body yeah your body overreacts for sure
and you hear how I here's what I'm I
want you to do stop being afraid of your
own body because what you're going to
end up doing is you're going to start
asking yourself what are you trying to
protect me from that sentence changed my
life cuz I'd put my hand on my chest and
I'd say what are you trying to protect
me
from my things was the economy every
time I looked at a I saw a red Ticker on
the ticker tape a little red arrow
pointing down my body B dropped into my
my stomach dropped it was game time it
was fight or flight every time I got a
bill in the mail woo I it was it would
never stop you can't live like that
right but I started asking myself what
are you trying to protect me from oh
from the stock market of course it's
going to crash the people are crazy
and of course it's going to just keep
coming back until it
doesn't yeah and it was this gentle dude
my body's working awesome it's just
identified the wrong
villain but you have to decide to give
up the identity that I'm crazy because
you're
not yeah that's I guess I never really
thought about it that way but I I
definitely do when I think about who I
am that is at the top of the list it's
I'm I'm a scaredy cat I'm afraid of
everything you're not you're not you're
a little girl wondering what what you
did so badly what was so bad about you
that your dad treated you like
that yeah that that makes sense tonight
I want you to write that eight-year-old
girl a
letter and say dear 8-year-old Lexi I
freaking love you and I'm holding you as
tight as I can because that should not
have happened to
you and if I'd been your mom that
wouldn't have
happened I can do that okay you got to
let that little girl go and you might be
a 10-year-old and there might be a
15-year-old and as you write these
letters more crap's probably going to
come up but I want you to slowly sit
with them and I want you to make that a
practice I've got several letters
written to myself over the years here's
another I want to give you this this
glimmer of hope before I'll let you go
okay because you and I could talk for
hours just kind of piecing this thing
together yeah but it I think more than a
bunch of tasks that you could Google at
the end of the day I think I need you to
hear me say you're not crazy I need you
to hear me last night
what
happened okay I've been sick and so I
was sleeping
upstairs in our guest room
okay it's right up it's it's a converted
Attic So it's right up against the
ceiling and last night the storms were
nuts yeah they were and I woke
up my heart was racing the wind was just
whipping the rain was so hard bam bam I
heard the trash cans flying around
outside cuz I live out in the
country
and I started
laughing I started laughing and I
thought man they are getting it out
there and then I said thank God we
needed this rain
bad and I rolled over and I got an 87 on
my sleep score last night which is
pretty high for me wow okay okay here's
why I tell you that I need you to
believe me that healing is possible if
you put this work in
okay you're going to have to have some
time in the darkness right they're and
they're probably going to have you draw
a picture of what of dark of a dark room
with a little kid in
it and if you want to do that with your
husband yall do it together because
don't do this by yourself but y'all to
draw a picture of just for a week at
nighttime just going to draw a picture
of a little kid in a room that's dark
and when your body starts going I want
you to feel it put your hand on your
chest and go man my body feels like
there's somebody coming in this door
right
now but I'm safe
now and then I want you to draw that
picture on a nightly basis or an
afternoon basis with your husband until
you don't uh until your body doesn't
take off on you
anymore okay and then right it's just
going to keep ramping up and ramping up
until you can't freaking wait for the
darkness and by the way every once in a
while I go into the house and I'm like
something doesn't feel right in here I
don't it's just trying to take care of
me again it's fine you see I'm not I'm
not I'm not going to war with my body
anymore
yeah that would be a great feeling would
that be awesome okay can you UND deare
war against Lexi starting today that
doesn't mean anything's going to be
better tomorrow you're still GNA have
trouble sleeping tonight all that let's
undec war from Lexi tonight and I want
you to put a journal by your bed
someone's prob already told you this
every irrational wild thought I want you
to write it
down okay okay M oh I heard the shutter
blow off someone's in the backyard we're
all going to die write that down get out
of your body and onto a piece of
paper okay okay mhm will you do that yes
I can do that that seems like a tangible
step will you and your husband come over
and get some free coffee and hang out
yes he would love that we actually saw
you one night at Five Guys um and my
husband was like that's John deloney I
had no clue who you were at the time and
I'm like who is who the heck is John
deloney he was like fangirling um and
then we he ended up showing me your show
and I've listened ever since but he
would yeah yall come up here tell them
tell them you on the show and that uh
we're going to hang out and then we'll
be it'll be awesome okay okay and um if
you come visit me in person I'll give
you a couple of names of some local
people that I trust that I think would
be worth seeing that would be amazing I
was going to ask if you could do that
thank you yes all right hang on the line
I'm going to hook you up with those free
books and um we'll get them shipped out
to you um and hope to see you guys in
the studio soon we'll be right
back
hey what's up deloney here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
as we wrap up today's show man um may be
my favorite new singer right now uh it
reminds me a lot of Mike Ness um but he
is uh singing some country music his
name is Zach Bryan what just I mean
anything he's putting out these days is
amazing song's called something in the
orange and it goes like
this it'll be fine by dusl I'm telling
you baby these things eat at your bones
and drive your young mind crazy but when
you place your head between my col and
jaw I don't know much but there's no
weight at all and I'm damned if I do and
damned if I don't cuz I say I miss you I
know that you won't but I miss you in
the mornings when I see the sun
something in the orange tells me we're
not
done go listen to every song Zack Bryan
has man he's pretty good pretty good he
actually he's amazing amazing love you
guys stand in cool see you
[Music]
soon